so today we're looking at the specifics
of elevations of places in in
Aristotle's ethics and the reason we
want to do this is it's nice to know
these sort of general things about
virtue advice but you know if you're
going to think about things in terms of
virtue ethics you have to be a bit more
specific you have to think does this
person have this virtue or this vise and
then what actually constitutes this
virtue in this bites
and you notice Aristotle we can list all
the virtues and vices he talks about
from about halfway through book three
all the way through five but five is
devoted almost exclusively to one virtue
which is justice but one virtue is one
likes injustice right and the reason
that he does that is because virtue and
vice are not virtue but justice and
injustice are in a certain way more
complicated than the other issues and
vices and justice like he says in a
certain way is the whole of virtue so
you could think of it being just yes
exercising these virtues not just with
respect to yourself or you know your
family or your immediate surroundings
but with respect to your society you
know so to be courageous when your
society tells you that you need to be
courageous maybe say on the battlefield
that is also it's not just courage
that's also certainly justice if you're
doing what your community requires of
you so justice is a bit more complicated
we'll talk about I'm going to actually
put that one off till at the end of
class because we want to look at these
which I think are easier to wrap your
heads around but this is the listing so
there's there's eleven different
virtuous states that are you know
genuine virtues for Aristotle that we
can look at and go into detail each of
them he has spices as opposed to them so
we look at this you're all familiar with
this scheme and I you know virtue is in
the middle vices at the death the
extremes there's vices of too much not
enough then the Goldilocks solution just
right but it's not just a matter of
amount or degree it's a matter of all
these other things the right person of
the right time in the right way for the
right reasons and I've given you some
some sort of charts to help you make
sense of it I'm still developing some of
those I'll be posting those on either
for you hopefully all of them this
weekend but if you already have three of
them one for temperance reality one for
magnificence so if you've looked at that
and you realize that Aristotle's ideas
are not just you know finding the middle
position it's finding the middle
position in the right way at the right
time all these sort of qualifications
come in one other thing I want to remind
you of so virtue is the thing to aim for
Vice is the thing to avoid does that
mean all of you are either virtuous or
vicious
maybe doing virtuous actions makes you
virtuous vicious actions makes you mix
vicious he was doing actions from alive
why aren't you all virtuous ambitious
right now such as them there's like a
middle place in between I mean there is
kind of a continuum here
remember how Aristotle says you could be
doing just the actions but not be a just
person yet a lot of that has to do with
this for the right reason I mean I'm
guessing that most of you are pretty
law-abiding citizens right Marisa Marisa
students tend to tend to be pretty
law-abiding are you lop binding because
you recognize that that's the right
thing to do and you actually desire to
do that or are you law-abiding because
you don't want to get punished or does
it you know sort of a mixture with some
things you're doing because you
recognize it to be the right thing other
things like observing you know something
like the speed limit we talked about
that earlier the semester almost none of
us actually do observe the speed limits
but we tend to think that ten over is
too much are you doing that just because
you don't want to get co-op you know or
you don't want people to think you're a
bad person
well if you're doing it for those
reasons you're not completely just yet
likewise you know if you do bad things
maybe some of you do do bad things I
don't know I'm guessing that you do
they're probably more things like having
to do with good temper or maybe courage
or or temperance or liberality not so
much with with justice but if you do bad
things is it because you're actually a
bad person you're a vicious person or
are you somebody who could turn out to
be a vicious person
continue on that track that isn't there
yet those are those are distinctions
they are stumbled and make those are
distinctions you want people to make
when you think about people look at
somebody's characteristic behavior if
they're always over here there's
something wrong with that person not
just wrong with them psychologically but
wrong with them morally they're over
here it's because they want to be over
here on some level they get something
out of that they desired that if they're
over here not just some of the time but
almost all the time their virtuous their
where we're of human being ought to be
they're the ones that you want to look
up to it uses reference was so what
we're gonna do today is we're gonna look
at some of these virtues in detail I'm
not going to look at all there are some
things too like Aristotle points out
they're not exactly virtues but they do
have to do with our emotions and there
could be the middle state they think
about a shame all right all of you have
talked shame I think at one point or not
if you haven't then your genius that's
bad because a shameless person will do
just about anything
shameless is something that helps to let
us know at least in some cases we're
doing the wrong thing where we're in the
wrong condition and now it could be over
things that are fairly trivial in the
big scheme of things like you know you
can be
Jane say cypresses right now you do the
stupid play and they score a goal or you
screw up you know somebody setting up
for a goal how do you feel sense of
shame right something didn't go the way
it ought to have go on
you may feel a sense of shame sometimes
with rating right hand in the paper you
think it's really great you get it back
it's covered with red ink oh wow
because I didn't know this and I didn't
do what I was supposed to do and I feel
stupid you know that sort of thing right
we've all felt something like I have
myself it's actually much worse if
you're smart because if you're smart
you're used to always getting things
right and then when you don't get things
right then you really think those sense
of shame now just some people to feel
too much shame more than they ought to I
think you all know people like that
maybe some of you are like that's that's
an extreme some people feel no shame
when they want to feel shame there's
something wrong with that - there's a
right amount to feel likewise with you
know pleasure and other people's
accomplishments you know if it really
bothers you that other people are doing
wrong there's a problem right if you
really enjoy seeing other people get
hurt that's a problem - we're sort of a
middle position between those with the
rest of these you can think of them in
terms of gas and reason out you know
just for instance we're not going to
talk much about this but ready with this
is one I think all of you can relate to
very easily we all you know well not all
of us not necessarily somebody could be
a vice of efficiency but we recognize
the value of the human right you guys
like the laugh when they can watch
comedy shows why do we let them because
it's it's plus right why do we tell
jokes to each other or you know
sometimes make up jokes on the spot
we're laugh at each other stories that's
part of the good life isn't it that's
part of social life and you may do it on
Facebook you know your friends inside
kind of stuff is it possible to put it
into this scheme oh like carousel with
us yeah there's a right amount to enjoy
yourself and thank mom it's not like
there's just one tiny specified amount -
its kind of arranged but can somebody go
to five people ever go too far with you
or you ever felt offended
that's not just what they were making
fun of somebody you liked or something
but you thought this really went too far
this is this is important
yeah watch the wheels Comedy Central
roasts if you can example that they are
really vicious that's an example of
humor that's actually going to the
vicious extreme can somebody if you
lacking a sense of humor Aristotle calls
people like that bores people like
buffoons we we use other words like you
know they're always screwing around as a
matter of fact as though there's a whole
genre in cirno's a show that it became
movies called jackass and one of those
guys do they're always screwing around
and doing things like you know shooting
each other on the cannons or you know
writing grocery carts and it's supposed
to be funny but you know is that the
right amount no excessive lets the
music-appreciation class
we did somebody like showing a lot of
movies okay so let's think about some of
these other ones let's think about
courage as a matter of fact can you do
all of you your cards up to me and we'll
look at some of these yeah well I want
you to do all this well let me let me go
through the instructions so what I want
you to do with those note cards that I
handed out is I want you to think of for
each of these I want you to write these
down so you have nine blanks that you're
going to think nine things with three
categories so we've got virtues and
vices with temperance and
self-indulgence and Sensibility so I
mean if you've been reading the
Aristotle if you've been studying this
stuff if you've been using you know like
for instance the chart that I actually
gave you for this there should be a
smile shouldn't be very hard to do you
should actually know what temperance
looks like courage virtue of courage of
the vices associated that that
magnificence with giving wealth on a
larger scale I want you to think of
famous people people that we can use as
examples that everybody can can relate
you who fit into these bowls so think of
somebody who actually you would think is
courageous somebody who you think is a
coward somebody who you think is
foolhardy
down you know the bottom one somebody
who's a public figure who he has well
who does give the right amount you know
on a large scale like some of the people
maybe who built your buildings you know
all your buildings that are named after
somebody here on campus and your reason
they're named after somebody they gave
that money people who don't give their
fair share and I'm people who
do it but they do it in such a way as to
just draw attention to themselves and to
you know trying to make a big name for
themselves so I want you to think about
about those and I'm going to use those
in this example this as we as we go
through this so let's take one of these
then that's not let's look at what
Arizona calls liberality so liberality
has to do with giving and taking wealth
or property or possessions and I would
actually myself argue that it could also
include time so here's a volunteer that
could be an example of liberality
another word that we have for this is
generosity what makes a person generous
it's a matter of giving and taking right
yeah I gave you a sort of chart for this
that corresponds to what we know from
Aristotle's Nicomachean ethics from from
that that stuff in book form I sort of
put it into a table what what's the mean
what's the gist right well it has to do
with the amount that you you give more
than the amount that you take and at the
extremes of meanness or we might say
being stingy or tight-fisted or we have
all sorts of adjectives for that the
person who does not give enough and
they're more interested in taking than
gift the other extreme they give too
much or they give in the wrong ways
rather the wrong times
so we have all three things we have a
mean middle position we have one extreme
of deficiency and one extreme excess and
Aristotle calls that extreme of excess
product prodigality that's probably not
a term that you relate to very easily
although you could think of if you know
I fear that biblically inclined you can
think of the prodigal son
you know why he's called the prodigal
son when one goes off and spends all the
money in a foreign land and then comes
back nothing and his dad takes a minute
says oh I'm so glad you're back the
other son gets kind of mad and says I
work for you all this time and you never
gave me anything why are you gonna take
those deadbeats that might be who's a
deadbeat take those deadbeat in and
giving him all the nice stuff again
after he spent your money literally with
the fours
you know partying so they don't use of a
product all except where in that story
of the prodigal son we use other words
should talk about somebody spending
their money too freely
now what actually constitutes us me so
he has to do with giving giving wealth
the person who's in the right condition
the person is generous does that mean
they get to everybody in our society we
might think that Aristotle would say our
society is wrong that will not be
discriminated because the person who's
actually have the mean is discriminated
we often know if I use that word
discrimination we often think that's
what I'm adequately out thing doing I
was discriminated against now I get the
grounds for a lawsuit that's one kind of
discrimination if I if I discriminate on
you too
her grades based on their gender that
would be wrong wouldn't let's say I give
all the guys a new za and I make the
women work really hard and just give
them bees at the top level that would be
that would be wrong to do with them
what do you wouldn't think about that
speak up because you know it's a hopeful
way that keeps things from happening
when you actually stand up there things
what if I did it on the basis of race
I'd be wrong - you're right as we say
sexual discrimination is wrong racial
discrimination is wrong there's other
types you know we can talk about ageism
all of you are young so maybe I decide
well young people don't know anything so
I'm gonna give you all C's possibly I
mean ever thought of actually decided
you know don't start teaching people how
things until they're by thirst because
they don't have enough life experience
to make sense of it I actually think
it's wrong some people might not know
that would be wrong to tell stories how
else aren't you supposed to scream
that's supposed to discriminate against
age you're not supposed to family
against someone with a disability or
yeah we don't know my god we call it
sexism against jamberry we call it
racism in this race I don't have an ism
the other mobility disability ability of
people do they call it okay ableism Mary
yeah so that's a bad thing to
discriminate about about we're against
you're not supposed to discriminate
against people within veteran's status
or not you're not supposed to
discriminate at least in public
institutions on religious grounds does
it mean that you can't discriminate in
any ways that makes us sound like
discrimination is a pretty bad thing to
do right and we're all supposed to be
really open-minded and you know treat
everybody as if you know they all
deserve a fair shake Aristotle doesn't
say that Aristotle thinks that if you're
a generous person you don't get to
everybody you give to those who you know
the giving is actually going to make
things better maybe you don't keep the
bum on the corner 5 bucks maybe that's
not actually generosity
if you know the Kong on the corners
actually they will spend up you know
whatever that's gonna buy some liquor
Aristotle would say that's actually not
generosity
that's in some way prodigality giving
for the wrong reasons if you're giving
to people just because you feel pity
that's probably not a good reason to
together there's lots of people ready to
take your money over pity you get to see
the commercials right those are just
appeals to penny not saying she
shouldn't get to people
not saying they shouldn't be charitable
but Aristotle would suggest some very
judiciously apply charity some
discriminate charity he says you know
the the liberal person gives wealth to
others through spending and giving it
away to the right amount to the right
people at the right times for the right
things if you're actually trying to
benefit that bum on the corner which
might be OK for you to do is it better
just an applied boxers and better two
tickets to buy meal it that might be if
that's going to be generosity it's going
to be discriminating and what it's
giving the money for for the right
reasons people who are in the mean they
also take off for the right reasons
they're less concerned with taking
wealth than they are with giving love
that's what makes a person generous if a
person is much more concerned with
taking the gimmick they're happy beyond
their extreme they're their stingy and
we'll talk about that again in a moment
let's talk about prodigality though so
the prodigal person actually looks more
like the generous
you notice with the Aristotle he says
sometimes one of the extremes most
closer to the mean than the other one
it works that way with generosity and
prodigality the prodigal person is the
one who's always buying the drinks who's
always throwing the carnies and then he
has no money left over at the end of the
month and then they're the one hitting
you up for money at the other can just
make me alone when I was in the Army we
had a lot of guys like we would we'd all
get paid once a month and some guys
would drink their their money up within
like a week and then of course you know
it was pretty easy life in some respects
because we'll be eating in the chow hall
so if you ran out of money you could
still eat and you saw the roof over your
head because the government was getting
their bearings we said of clothing so
you weren't gonna be street but these
guys were living basically like you know
somebody way beyond their means and then
pretty soon they would want you to make
them alone and they would get very angry
if you didn't but if you did what was
gonna happen well you wouldn't get it
back what are they gonna do with it
yeah they'd spend it right away spending
for the wrong reasons not necessarily
even even too much of each individual
thing but buying too many individual
things spending on too many occasions
for the wrong things not thinking these
sort of things through not being
discriminating and where your money is
going what does that lead to that leads
the the generous person is actually
going to manage their money or their
property or their resources or their
time wealth and so they're actually
going to have money or time to give to
other people when it's needed the
prodigal person seems like they're the
kind of person you want to be around
party all the time but they're going to
run out a pretty quick and then they're
not going to have anything together and
then actually they may start you know
looking in in the wrong places for more
money together or more resources
together they may be driven to end up
doing the wrong things as a result you
actually don't want to get around ten
people you want to be around people who
are actually generous not people who are
proud of them and there are subtle talks
about two different kinds of accelerant
efficiency he talks about what he calls
the miserly or the stingy and what's
wrong with them
they they are more interested in taking
than giving and they just don't get much
right and they feel a lot of pain
the the generous person who feels
pleasure when we give to people actually
soon as the prodigal person they feel
like that's their you know all you've
done that's right you've given money to
people or your time in people and it
makes it feel good to some except not
you might be you might be miserly it
really hurts you to give money to a good
cause it's hard to let go of that dollar
well you might be of this this extreme
and that's that's not good that's not as
bad as the other type of extreme he also
talks about the greedy and greedy are
those we are willing to they really
desire to have wealth and they're
willing to
get from pretty much anywhere they can
get there they're not interested in
giving they're interested in taking in
accumulating and he says that these are
the people who will ply as he calls them
sorted trades you know when people are
involved in criminal enterprises is it
because they just have to feed their
family or is it because they really walk
about and they're willing to take it
from wherever they can get it they're
willing to sacrifice other values which
they often do recognize for the sake of
that one good well they desire wealth
too much it's easy to have to sympathize
with some people right the kid who's who
you know ends up becoming the local
person who organizes the
you know it's sort of like one step up
and down the hierarchy you know if
everybody around you seems to be you're
probably gonna be greedy too if you up
in poverty it's going to be hard not to
value well in a way that other people
don't and if you broke the property
probably also we're not getting a good
appreciation of the other bits of money
being driven home to over and over again
that wealth is important that's not
actually most people who end up flying
as is excellence and sort of trains them
they come from all walks of life you
know he gives examples of saying a
pimp's right you know we often talk as
if I'm sorry these kind of colorful
characters know what pimps are people
who seduce other people into
prostitution which is you know selling
your body for money something that if
you want to make money and give a lot
with a lot of people that you don't like
and tips are the people who keep them in
line and live off of them and when they
get out of mind beat them or kill them
then often drug them up that's what you
would call a sort of trade why does
somebody become a gun because they they
care more about gaining wealth that's
the central value for them Dan about
anything else that about say human
dignity or even what other people think
most people you know when you actually
look at communities you know we have
these these pimps that are the big
characters on TV and stuff like that
when you actually go to communities
where prostitution is taking place pimps
are not highly regarded people they are
considered to be scholars and there's a
good reason Aristotle say yeah they are
the greedy they are among the group
there's a lot of other people who are
greedy to you didn't even do it at a
very high level what's one of the
biggest you guys are all familiar with
these big
that's going on downtown take take Wall
Street then nobody's quite sure you know
what they want to where they're going
but there's one thing that's pretty
clear there's a mad about breathe now
you know whether Wall Street people in
general are greedy or not there's
certainly a public perception of it
isn't that they're basically just
interested in making money and that
people's jobs or lives were dignity or
any of these other things or holding
communities together our little values
if that's really the case then they
would fit into Aristotle's category of
the greedy well have you written
something down on your on that so let's
let's look now at Kirsch we'll start
with the courage as I think that's a
virtue that is easier for us to wrap our
heads around and relate to it partially
because we're you know the dramas the
narratives that we like to look at and
we like to think about even though we're
not you know courageous all that often
you probably are a courageous more often
than you think
why encourage broadly we have a lot of
dramas will receive
by dating and things so versatile
courage before I look at these examples
so courage has to do with two things
besides the actions destitute with two
kinds of emotions emotion of fear that
ones we recognize pretty easily courage
is mastering or fairly often settles and
then the emotion of confidence and these
are sort of opposites to each other but
you can feel them at the same time that
maybe you've ever been try to think of
some examples I mean for me the examples
like getting in a fight and you're
feeling that sense of fear but you're
also feeling excited at the same time
and you know you don't want to curve
getting hit hurts right but then it's
also kind of the thrill and then you
relate to the stuff like that I mean
there's there's other extreme sports
things that are kind of like that I
think you go snowboarding down the mouth
and maybe there's something like that
yes you've got like you know football
the clash takes place there's kind of an
excitement with that and you have to
overcome that that feeling maybe getting
hurt same thing for soccer soccer is
very
I played basketball those 2-cent pick
some people get follow them off and they
get hurt what else is like that yeah
yeah but that's all it is the whole
things punching the other guy right but
can we think of anything that's not
necessarily sports or one thing about
going into a negotiation not for most of
you at this point what is it going to be
most likely car did you not find houses
yeah you'd have to get a really good
deal
some people actually get kind of a
thrill war here's a great example how
many of you I'll ask a couple questions
how many of you ever have a fear of
public speaking almost all of them
interesting how many of you still have a
fear of speaking
oh actually about anthem Wow
do you guys have to take a speech class
here at Marist one of the reasons that a
lot of schools make it take a speech
class is to help you overcome back that
fear of public speaking
I think maybe next next semester when I
teach this class again I'll incorporate
something the presentations will help
students work their way through that now
you get up to talk about something and
let's assume that you're actually
prepared you know you come in your no
cards no card are out of order you can
also even feel that sense of fear but
also a sense of confidence because
you're prepared right just as much as
when you've learned the place you feel
that sense of anxiousness am I gonna
screw it up but also well I am prepared
for this sort of way so courage gets to
do with them and the courageous person
feels both of those emotions and then
they manage them properly and what is
courage you have to do
yes to do with things that are by their
nature scary it's right to actually feel
fear the first time that you have to
speak in public it's right actually to
feel fear when you are putting your body
on the line and you may get your leg
broken or your color or God knows what
else
it's right to feel fear loss it's
registered to her walk into the boxing
practice you don't there's something
wrong at that point and if you don't
feel fear at all you are actually at the
vicious extreme those are the fool argue
those are the rash people I remember
I'll tell you a story it's funny to me
you know I used to do martial arts and I
was studying karate and I was working
you know restaurant jobs and stuff like
that
cuz I have no intention of going to
college I was going to go into the army
after I finished high school well then
there was like a delay for the thing I
wanted to do so just working as dead-end
restaurant jobs and then studying karate
working out so there was an older guy
this is what I was working at Kentucky
Fried and so there's this older guy who
was who transferred over to our store
and my older I mean you know now you
know he was probably in his mid to late
20s and it was kind of a badass you know
and he said he thought out that I was
into martial arts and he says I'm into
martial arts too I do they do Tai Chi
and this is math and I said lots of cool
I don't know that you want to work out
together or something like that said
yeah that sounds great
we're gonna where to start a sparring
and then he gave me this address he said
meet me here at like 10:00 and 10
o'clock and I was like that's kind of
weird so I looked it up and he'd given
me the image to a bar yeah and I said
what up to it I said so we're gonna work
out the bar he said yeah what I do is
for practices that go in and I just
start fights up guys they have and I
said well you know that doesn't actually
sound like martial arts that sounds just
more like getting in fights with guys
and you know I was like 18 anyway so you
know we're gonna go to a bar where I may
not get into the first place and then
just go to start fights with people I
don't know that's what this guy did
that's an example of being for this guy
had no sense of fear whatsoever he was
literally crazy
he ended up electrified electrocuting
himself
we have this big fryer called a ten and
three or ten four and it would cook like
20 chickens at a time big deep pressure
cooker and I had a complicated you know
set of machines inside and it broke down
and this is a big catastrophe when this
thing breaks down because Kentucky Fried
really relied on that that fryer and
you're not supposed to try to fix it
yourself you're supposed to wait for the
engineer to come who actually knows what
he's doing this guy that wasn't there
that thing shows you how foolhardy was
he got inside this Friday and started
monkeying around
he didn't pull the electrical cord he
didn't unplug it and of course he got
electricity because that's that's not
you know just 110 that's 220 and that
will fry it and he died later on not not
right away
people who are affording you may think
that they're the ones that you want
watching your back
or you know
defending your country or you know being
your fireman or things like that but you
don't actually want people who work
because they will actually go out of
their way to to find dangerous
situations to be in you want somebody
who's actually courageous who feels some
fear but then reacts it the right way I
notice again - people often mix these up
don't they
that's where we'll be interesting to
look at yours
comments are easy to tell how the powers
behave well let me ask you this that's
that's the action what a cowards feel
they feel too much what fear and not
enough confidence right
and sometimes they act when it's a tough
situation and there is something
actually scary what do they do they
don't they they let you down they don't
have your banner they break formation
they don't follow through on what
they're supposed to do there though you
know is there doing public speaking
maybe they feel too much fear they just
totally thing along and remember these
are habitual things it's not just
somebody who does that once if you find
yourself afraid and you back down once
that doesn't make you a coward yet
that's doing that repeatedly but if you
do do that over and over and over again
then you will become a coward and you
won't be able to stand up to the things
that are you know actually scary but
need to be stood up - let's look at some
of your examples so one for a current
Martin Luther King good example Martin
Luther King good I don't know if you
guys know this the the marchers the the
protesters back that they actually had
to go through a training program
that these black churches like the one
that Martin Luther King was pastor of
would run and one of the things that
they would do to prepare or what they
knew was coming because back then it
wasn't you know getting sprayed pepper
spray or something like that it was fire
hoses with water pressure that would
tear your skin off dogs who it would you
know might be living how are you and
cops who would break your head with the
sticks they'd also get all their
protesters throw bricks at you yeah what
they did was they would actually have
you go through something like it go on
but if you were going to be a protester
the other protesters you know in your
group and they would do all sorts of
terrible things at you and then push you
around stuff like that and if you
couldn't take that they wouldn't let you
go out there and protest because they
wanted people who had real courage the
way you develop courage is by acting
courageous so if you were going through
that gauntlet and you then you broke
down you wouldn't be any good to them
they needed people who were really
courageous they really didn't want
people who are forty did they because
what would that would that do then we
get the dogs sometimes and you couldn't
deal with people so that's a good
example here we've got three so Lance
Armstrong as being the greatest person
tosh point-o
touch point zero I don't know maybe that
is Dez full Guardians and Tiger Woods as
a coward that's kind of interesting I
could understand better plants the Lance
Armstrong one fighting cancer
I was Tiger Woods it's our does anybody
see how that would enhance Tiger Woods
you know but some of these are going to
get in this so let's let's check out
some of these other ones
oh so encourage Simba from Lion King
cowardice
Chucky's from Rugrats I don't know that
cartoon was like my kids didn't watch
that one but I'm assuming that's some
characters though it's like giving it
steve-o from jackass yeah some of those
guys on that show jackass the things
that they do they are they they'll have
a sense of fear and they want to there's
actually another show like that I used
to like to watch Conrad girls there's
three girls that would be similar stunts
and some of the things that they did
were pretty nuts let's see who else oh
this is good for courage the pilot who
landed in the Hudson River you guys
remember that was yeah that does take
courage and a lot of people probably
would have frozen up and then crash the
plane so that's the case where one
person's courage and
being instrumental in saving of their
lives
Plaxico and this cool horny I guess it
makes sense bin Laden as power wait that
might work well I've been allowed to be
be a coward well he's not a coward maybe
yeah but when it comes to bin that if we
got to think that for us is a coward but
thanks for his people they think of them
as courageous yeah
standing up to the great tyrant the USA
all that sort of stuff I you know maybe
there is something to high suspected
when it comes down to it a lot it wasn't
another comma because it takes it takes
something to be able to see through
something like that you might say well
because he was on the sidelines he was
directing things from from behind he
wasn't actually been flying the planes
okay soldier who recently received the
Medal of Honor usually that's it for
courage Steven Steve Irwin oh this force
alarm eNOS nor the crocodile injure I
think that makes sense he got killed
with a sort of freaky accidents and what
was really surprising about that was not
that particular freak accident but then
he hadn't been killed before that wasn't
he'd gone through all these crazy things
kill them and then they got hit by that
one-in-a-million chance of the Stingray
Pearson is just so these are these are
good examples look all you some more of
these let's look at some of these other
virtues and vices now so we've talked
about courage to talk about liberality
let's think about temperance or another
word for it is moderation or
self-control so what is that with
respect to that's with respect to
certain pleasures certain bodily
pleasures Arizona actually is very
restrictive about what he counts with
that we would say all food drink
pleasures of sex there's other pleasures
of the senses that you have you know
listening to music watching TV I suppose
that for some people dancing or doing
athletics working out could be a matter
of temperance because all these things
can be as you work out it is painful
right some of the working out but it's
also pleasure after a while that's why
people get it worked out there's a right
amount at the right time for the right
reasons
there's too much and then there's
there's not enough now do you know a lot
of people who enjoy pleasures too little
know where there are some right there
are some people who have who take less
pleasure things and they ought to do
physical things could because there's
something wrong with their body you know
if you there's a shot over at the
culinary who had cancer I didn't forget
whether it was cancer of the throat or
the tongue or something like that and he
lost his sense of taste imagine they
have a chef without a sense of taste
that would be sort of like being a great
musician
your sense of hearing which did happen
didn't they don't who continued to write
symphonies after he was death
because he had that great of a mastery
of his epistle this guy is actually
still cooking I'm teaching classes
because he knows the way things want to
taste and he remembers that but that
would really be a great loss wouldn't it
now imagine you've been born without a
real sense of taste your whole life
would be very enjoyable with it I mean
if you take away the good taste from
food think about a roast food is all
that chewy saliva swallowing things you
know if it didn't taste so so great I
doubt a lot of us want to do it you know
there are some people who take must
pleasure to the man they want to and the
Aristotle calls that leave the
insensible more often it's a matter of
the the opposite extreme goes so how are
the ways that we'd we go to excess with
respect sometimes we enjoys it too much
right I'm doing evidence of that I
didn't get this physique by exercising
all right how did I get it any more than
I should
drinking
yes believe it or not when I was your
age I weighed like about 180 pounds and
then for most of grad school is about
190 because I used to work out three
hours a day which was against excessive
wasn't a lot of uh servers are prone to
accesses in the Walkman we've replaced
one access we get that under control we
have move places with another knowing
how many of you think that you might
watch too much TV or spend too much time
on the Internet
only a few that would be an example of
this too why do we do that because we
enjoy it right it's pleasurable well
people don't don't watch TV because it
pains them they watch it because they
enjoy it
how many of you can't live without music
on at least four hours of your day none
of it a lot of people who that's that's
the case to find themselves unable to
work because of some journalists with
music that may be
well yeah you're right addicted to
something then do it so much that it
actually does hurt you and one thing
that sort of constitutes an addiction is
once you become addicted if you don't
get the object of your addiction you
feel a lot of pain cigarettes well
things are created
I don't know hopefully none of you smoke
cigarettes or tobacco because they've
been spending a lot of time on making
sure that young people don't but I
smoked before I started smoking when I
was 17 and I smoked cigarettes like
about a packed pack and a half day until
I was 27 and then I switched to cigars
and I smoked cigars about two or three
cigars a day because they pack a lot
eighteen and they taste really great
until I was about 33 34 and the only
reason I quit quite frankly was because
I developed an allergy to negati Archer
took back and so I'm ahead for about a
year I wouldn't have a smoke you know
big cigar and then I would get all
congested and I would tell myself I just
got a cold and I was happening every day
and then I finally realized you know I
hurt my body a lot because of that yeah
why did I do that probably cuz I didn't
love the feeling smoking my smoker is do
it and if I didn't get it I felt awful
you know people get addicted to coffee
they become addicted to alcohol right
drink enough alcohol your body's you
become too crazy we have all sorts of
drugs that are going to much more
powerful than that
well some people become addicted when it
comes to bodily pleasures people become
addicted to eating various eating
disorders right how people develop it's
through a situation nobody just becomes
you know addicted to this we're addicted
to that just one time it required us
doing it several times some things that
are not as naturally addicting good to
do it over and over and over again
I suppose you to become addicted to
music people become addicted to exercise
if they don't they don't get that
exercise they feel terrible not just
physically mentally people become
addicted to the sex right leading them
into all too risky situations LEDs so
that's you know those are all problem
examples so let's see what we've got for
some examples ok so so maybe put down
with advice excess I think it's much
Charlie Sheen I think you can make a
good case that Charlie Sheen very
self-indulgence in a grand scale you
know lots of prostitutes pretty much
doing anything you want us it's
surprising the guy's still alive and so
somebody else shows Charlie Sheen for
the next one
very good temperate there that's
interesting there is probably something
to that if you want to have it as a
being a coach that's a tough job to be a
coach you wouldn't actually have to be a
good coach you would actually have to be
tempered it's done sibility pimps
maybe because
themselves as much in there the product
i let's see who else we have for
temperance barack obama who by the way
is a smoker okay Louis used to sneak out
and then smoke cigarettes every once in
a while but you got it more or less
under control
I know if he still smokes self indulgent
Terrell Owens I think that a lot of
celebrities would probably be
self-indulgent another person's got
Charlie Sheen for self-indulgence that
seems to be a big consensus oh here is
interesting these might be a little bit
of mixed up the virtue somebody has
Wednesday low in town for being Tesla as
she like shaped up recently she got her
life back together
I mean his bluesy loan actually did get
a handle on things and got all of her
appetites under control and she would be
tempura I don't know if that's the case
right based on how she's been over the
years a lot of drinking partying that
sort of thing and then through the
Sensibility Chris Tucker
somebody else's linsdale oh and over
here for self-indulgence
and then phone home for temperance I
suppose he's little rock-and-roll
lifestyle for a long time that doesn't
seem to screw to bother and then the
Kardashians for insensibility for not
appreciating pleasures sufficiently yeah
I don't know is that does everything
true for you guys Kardashians I don't
watch the show so maybe watch them do
you think do you think they would fit on
the side of not enjoying physical
pleasures that much some people don't
know tell me so if they really like the
pleasures they neither the temperate or
they'd be something honest today there
is something dull okay I mean I think
most celebrities from in our culture
problem with me because they have so
much access to pleasures and pleasures
you know they drop in because there's
their fun and we enjoy some keys got
Homer Simpson herself and doesn't
definitely I mean you know they make
whole episodes out of his is one vice or
another advice you know too much
doughnuts too much beer too much coffee
let's look now at another one let's look
at magnificence like I said earlier if
you walk around their college campus
they walk around any college campus all
the buildings have names why do they
have names we're the name sometimes
they're named different important
administrators exactly people who
donated the money and that's how you get
your name loans or scholarships you know
I'm going to be the so with sort of
Memorial Scholarship it's usually after
they die so a lot of a lot of things on
campus exist because people who have
money or have money donated and that's
what makes things like a college work if
your college we actually right now given
the economy the way it is you're
actually better off with your college is
more what we call tuition dependent
based on the students coming in and
taking the money from them than if it's
what we call endowment dependent the
endowment is the money that people have
given to the college over the years and
it's been set aside in this big whoop
you know this big account that's
invested like say in the stock market
now the stock market is down has been
down for a while
so if you you know your endowment is
smaller that means you can do less stuff
because they use the interest to you
know so you can buy new buildings what
about other things do people give in our
society in other ways Greek society was
like you know building and trying to you
know literally financing part of the
Navy we're putting on a coral show
putting on a drama or paying for
religious thing what do people do in our
society what do they give money for on
the large scale can you think of any
examples cancer yeah those people would
give cancer research I'm thinking where
it's like one big donor who's giving
money orthos yeah yeah the Bill and
Melinda Gates Foundation right the most
inclu the actor if they gave a name for
some of their wealth first they're still
like millionaires because of that but
say they created these gigantic
foundations you know if you listen to
the radio or watch TV you will see
things like the Ford Foundation the
Rockefeller Foundation Carnegie
Foundation all these foundations were
created by rich people they were ways to
give back to the community if you go
around here
most of the local libraries where did
they come from
Andrew Carnegie ended up actually giving
the money to build a lot of those
libraries what else do people get so
that's you know foundations scholarships
colleges anything for our entertainment
sometimes you pull up build stadiums or
you know provide a show
nowadays you know how to build stadiums
big tax everybody have a stadium for the
team is gonna go away so we're gonna you
know let me attacks or $7.00 for a hot
dog yeah whole there's that too
they're making some good money there but
a lot of the things that we sort of take
for granted some of them were built by
businesses just to make a profit on you
now the railroads didn't come in through
some LAN through P the railroads came in
because people wanted enough to get that
you here to there and they were going to
charge you money for other they were
notorious actually for screwing over the
farmers Midwest but a lot of things that
constitute the world that you live in
are the product somebody is magnificent
magnificent comes from the Latin word
that literally means to do great things
we think of magnificent is like you know
the thing itself a magnificent piece of
architecture
well the real magnificence was somebody
giving the money paying for that to take
place and you can do it in you know a
huge scale you can do it on a smaller
scale but that is the virtue of then
what's the vice fall Gary some people
give and they don't give to accomplish
great things they don't give for
instance they might they might create a
new who say football stadium but not
because the town actually needs it but
because they want to make a big name for
themselves and they're going to find
something to do it and they happen like
football you know it couldn't even be
out of smaller scale they sponsor the
Little League teams but not because they
actually care about the development of
these kids or see it as a good thing
they just
get their name out there right that's
what aerosol calls well gear report
picks what's the what's that's the
access what's the deficiency not give
you notice that for Aristotle there's
this idea that if you're wealthy you
ought to be contributing back to society
and it's not because well you always
society or something like that but they
a lot of us tend to think about it you
make money off of our backs you know
that's her business
it's rather that if you're a rich person
if you that means you're a social
creature if you're not actually of your
own free will wanting to contribute to
society there's something wrong you you
have a vicious character we don't have a
virtuous character okay so here some
examples that people have Bill Gates for
magnificence the only one the Gates
Foundation I think that would that would
qualify did he do it just to make it a
big name for himself I don't think so
James you just Scrooge that's a good one
screwed you have a lot of money you
didn't give any of it to anybody until
you have this you know I guess religious
conversion
it's a